hi this is nathan Cole the writer and
producer of the waterhole lucky enough
to be a film courage interactive alumni
let me tell you if you live in Los
Angeles if you like independent film or
if you're involved in the paper film you
must come down here and check out one of
their events bringing a lot of great
people together that typically wouldn't
have an outlet and there's a lot of
choices to see movies in this town and
you know to see something like this
where you get to actually meet all the
people involved and really nice people
but you got to take advantage of it so
please come out check out them courage
interactive